من فيرجينيا
المهندس السابق في وكاله ناسا ومحرر مدونه
برنامج الفضاء الامريكيه اهلا بك معنا
يبدو ان الامريكيين هم اكثر الناس اهتماما
بموضوع الاطباق الطائره المجهوله لكن
طالما انه لم يحصل اي تواصل مع اي جهه
يمكن وصفها بانها ذكيه خارج اطار الكوكب
يكفي هذا دليل على انه لا يوجد في الحقيقه
اي شيء هناك
يظهر اننا كلنا تحدثنا عن هذا الامر في
ثقافتنا هذه المخلوقات الفضائيه وكل واحد
منا لديه فكره عن ما راه في التلفاز عما
يجب ان تحتويه تلك الصور لكن صدقا لقد
اكتشفنا لم نكتشف اي دليل على حياه في اي
عالم اخر ما عدا عالمنا لكن الناس ما
يزالون يطرحون هذه الاسئله واناك متخصص
بالوجيه كنت اعمل في برامج الفضاء هنالك
اهتمام حقيقي لدى الجميع وهذا ما كان
هنالك حياه اخرى بالتالي هذان الاوراني
يتصادمان وهنا الان معكم اتحدث الى
التلفاز مع صديقي الاخضر
طيب يعني الناس تقول انها اجرت اكثر من
800 حاله مشاهده لظواهر غير
معروفه توصلت الى انه بين اثنين الى خمسه
بالمئه من اجمالي تلك المشاهدات ربما تكون
غير طبيعيه ما الذي نفهمه من ذلك
ما تم تفسيره في ذلك الاجتماع انه غالبا
عندما نرى هذه الصور اليوم لانه بعض
الاشخاص قد التقطوا صورا لها في هواتفهم
النقاله الهواتف النقاله بالملايين هي حول
العالم وهي مصممه لاخذ صور لنا لحيواناتنا
الاليفه هي ليست افضل الادوات لاخذ صور
علميه بالتالي نضيف هذا الامر الى حقيقه
ان الناس قد يخطئون شيء برؤيته ويفسرونه
على انه شيء اخر وقد ننتهي قد ننتهي بنا
المطاف بعده صور لا نفهمها لا يعني ان هذا
الامر انها موجوده ما لم نفهمه ربما لحد
الان
بناء على هذا على الحديث الذي تفضلت به هل
يمكن الثقافه العامه التي تتحدث عن ان
البنتاغون وهناك كثير من الاشاعات حول ان
البنتاغون يخفي هذا الامر عن الجمهور
الامريكي وهو رساله تبدو متكرره في مسلسل
مثل اكسفايل والحقيقه
كما تقول
في اكس فايل يطفي ذلك شيئا من الرعب
والخوف للناس بان هناك ما يتم اخفاءه
حقيقه
هو امر ثقافي كما ذكرت سابقا يريد الناس
ان يعرفوا ويعجبهم ويتمنى انهم ان يؤمنوا
بان هنالك مخلوقات فضائيه هذه فقط امور
ثقافيه
الفضائي او ربما الشخصيات الخياليه التي
كانت قبل مئه عام كانت تحل محلها شخصيات
الكابوي والهنود الحمر لكن اعتقد ان الامر
مهم مهم بالعنصر الانساني لان من اننا
نريد ان نكون جزءا من منظومه فهم هذا
الكون ونريد ان نستمر بطرح الاسئله ونقول
هل هذا مخلوق فضائي هذا هي هذه هي هذا
التفسير الذي استطيع ان اقدمه لكم اقول ان
الناس هم الذين يريدون ان يصدقون ذلك لكن
لماذا ناس من الاساس عقدت هذه الجلسه لمده
اربع ساعات وفي الختام تقول مازلنا ندرس
الوضع ونجمع ادله اليس ناس هي التي ربما
تطرح هذه الشكوك وتجعل الناس يفكرون بان
هناك بالفعل المخلوقات فضائيه
اؤكد لكم انني كنت اعمل مع اشخاص سيعرفون
اذا ما كانوا كانوا هنالك مخلوقات فضائيه
ولم يقولوا اي شيء اذا ما تم اكتشاف
مخلوقات فضائيه ستتحدث عن هذا الامر في
اليوم التالي اقول ذلك انا دائما انتقدت
ناسا لهذه
الاحاديث الرسميه هم في حقيقه الامر لا
يريدون ان يعترفوا انه سبب وجودهم ان
الجميع مهتم بالمخلوقات الفضائيه هذا هو
سبب وجودهم وفي اي حكومه
في حقيقه الامر هم لا يتحدثون الى الناس
لكنهم يصدرون بيانات شخصيا وبسبب خبرتي في
العمل لدى ناسا انه اذا ما وجدوا اي دليل
لوجود حياه اخرى في الكون اعتقد انه سيكون
امرا في بالغ الاهميه في حياتهم بالتالي
سيطلع
وننا عليه لا اعتقد ان هنالك اي مخلوقات
فضائيه مجمده في داخل بنات الامر غير
موجود ما هذا الذي تحمله بين يديك اشكرك
جزيل الشكر سيد كيت كونج المهندس السابق
في وكاله ناسا ومحرر مدونه برنامج الفضاء
الامريكي حدثنا من جورجينيا شكرا جزيلا لك